hey everyone um i ah
good morning good afternoon good evening
depending where you are and welcome to
the today's talk theoretically speaking
lecture from the simons institute
on the mathematical essence of aging and
just to say a word even before i've seen
a part of this talk before and it really
made me change my habits
um we'll see how that reverses the aging
or slows it down
but the joking aside let me just tell
you some
serious stuff
and that is first of all uh you'll have
the opportunity to ask questions during
the webinar and and
and uh he actually encourages it and uh
i think he's going to actually force us
to ask questions and to do so just type
your question into the q a at the bottom
of the control panel
and he will address as many of the
questions as you can during the
uh the lecture and afterwards um
by the way my name is jeffy golda so i'm
the i
i am the director of the institute and
um
the simon says student just a few words
about it it was established in 2012
with a grant from the simon foundation
uh our mission is to bring together
the world's uh researchers in
theoretical computer science and related
field
to come and study pro and solve problems
together and
define models and investigate the nature
and limits of computation
um and uh we pride ourselves at trying
to
use the tools and the perspective of
computer science in other related fields
and such
are always fascinated by progress in
other fields
that has in a sense some computational
aspect computational perspective
i think that the talk today is a
wonderful example of that
um we uh
today's talk um is going to be given by
a distinguished speaker or we alone we
alone is a professor of systems biology
advisement institute
he has incredibly creative and highly
cited research which has looked at
gene expression network motifs the
design and principles of biological
networks
and all using both computational biology
and traditional web laboratory
biology and so forth and we
actually comes from background of
physics and mathematics
and he uh got his phd in physics at
weizmann
and then he became um um a biologist or
a systems biologist but i think that
he's brings a
perspective into biology and he in fact
i think includes both
biologists and physicists working
together to understand the principles of
molecular systems
that guide the decision of of our bodies
and um uh only has many
featured articles and videos on youtube
such as i think sunday at the lab and
how to give a good talk
and he's been awarded many awards
breakthrough
in life science award on his network
motif and
2017 jack solovey chair in physics
he holds it i um
uh and i think the 2014 uh knackers on
the prize
by the human frontier science project i
am extremely happy
um to have willie join us he's uh
not only a great speaker and a great
scientist he's also a great
playback artist which is how i met him
first so
i'm looking forward to it i'm going to
pass the baton to you
thank you it's a pleasure to be here
hi everyone and i'm speaking to you from
israel from the galilee and which is a
kind of rolling hills and also has some
of israel's
only flowing streams we were in a
really flowing stream today with my kids
it was
exhilarating to see some water after
being locked up
in corona times cove at 19
and to get my mind off the news
and off the exponential rise and into
some
nature was very very relaxing
and then yeah i realized we're all in
one boat we're just talking to shafi
about what it's like
in your area and the whole world is in
in
one boat in this case and we're also
there's another thing where in one boat
is we're all going to get old and die
and not all get old but we'll all die
i think and um aging is part
of our life and always has been
and when i was
studying physics but also biology i
always thought that physicists
there's nothing really interesting for
us about aging except for our
own aging process as personal as a human
being because i thought that aging was
a kind of a falling apart of the body
the kind of chaotic
loss of function decline
but um i changed my opinion changed
about that there's
fascinating things to talk about aging
in fact it's it's one of the great
open questions in biology and in
also there's tremendous advances of
understanding the core processes of
aging
and this picture that i put up here
is one picture that helped me really get
it
this was from um vanderson's lab
jan vanderson and an experiment from
2011 and a really
even more decisive one from 2016
about rejuvenation so these are two mice
and
they are um two years old the one on the
on the left this one looks like a
typical two-year-old mouse it's
you see the hunchback the fur mice live
about two two and a half years yeah
the look at the crumpled ears look at
the cataract
you can see this mouse is hardly running
on the wheel maybe
shivering um not very resilient there
this is
the other mouse is also two years old
they're the same age in fact they're
genetically identical they're twins
born from the same mom suckling from the
same
mom and but something was done to this
mouse
starting in middle age that slow down
the aging process and i mean
systemically so this mouse
has nice shiny fur and
nice shiny shiny ears and no cataract
and very perky and runs on the wheel
quite a lot and
um cancer is delayed and diabetes is
delayed all these things
and and on average this
mice with this treatment live about 25
longer
but the important thing here in my talk
is not about living longer
it's having less of this more healthy
aging how to
delay age-related diseases by addressing
the core process of aging so we know
that
doctors treat if you have heart disease
they treat heart disease
diabetes diabetes dementia
osteoarthritis they treat disease by
disease can we treat the core process of
aging that
was done here in these mice and
therefore in one fell swoop
delay all aging related diseases so how
can we understand that
and how can mathematics play a role in
understanding
this process i hope i got you interested
it's a good time to start typing
questions
in the q a i'm going to check the q a i
don't see any questions yet
but i'm going to start talking now and
soon i'm going to stop
and i'm not going to continue until
there's a question so
to rescue everyone start typing your
question i'm sure you have questions
already oh there's one already look
see did the mice look the same
a year previous so the answer
is yes and in fact
the treatment started about a year
previous so they started
they looked the same you can say a year
previous oh there's another question
i love it thank you it makes me feel
more connected
so what was down to mouse too i'm going
to tell you hold your horses
what is intervention solar energy i'm
going to tell you what aging slowed or
reversed
was aging slow to reverse so in many
cases you can say it was slowed
but some treatments given to very old
mice can reverse
some aspects i'll tell you about that
how long did mouse 2 live
so i don't know about this individual
but on average this population got to
treat and live 25
longer now i'm going to stop with the
questions i'm overwhelmed i'm joyous
thank you and we continue and keep
typing i'm going to check my questions
soon
okay so i'm going to try to now advance
the slide
i don't want to be stuck on just on this
slide oh
okay so yeah
i want to recognize omar karine a phd
student from math background
who did the theory theory work and my
collaborators valerie kejrinovski
while valerie is
an age a researcher of aging i don't
want to say aging researcher
in my department one floor down and i
made it as a phd student
so you know when we talk about aging
it's studied from multiple points of
view if you talk ask sociologists about
aging they'll say the most important
thing about aging
is if you are the lower your social
economic index
the faster you age the more diseases you
have in the and the sooner you die in
fact if you're
the difference between the top 90
percent and the bottom ten percent in
income
across cultures is ten years of life
even if you factor out health care so
that's important
but if you now go away from so or also
loneliness isolation etc
if we now that we're in corona time
isolating people in isolation
because of uh how do you call it in
america
house house safety i don't remember how
you call it but you may have to stay at
home
can make it very bad for some aged
people because of loneliness and
isolation
i can i talk about that but i want to
talk about biology
uh how it really and maybe we can
connect it to sociology
inside biology it's also studied from
two completely different disciplines
one is the theory of molecular damage
what kind of damage in our body
happens and causes aging and there's a
lot of damage theories
and exhaustion of stem cells
uh exhaustion of mitochondria that sells
energy factories
and loss of protein stability epigenetic
alterations
dna damage all these kind of each one of
these
stopping the body from repairing dna
damage makes you age faster there is
actually diseases like that called
progeria
also stopping the body from repairing
proteins make you age faster so
a lot of these damages are clearly
causal for aging
and so that's one way to think about
aging and then there's a completely
other way which has
been with us for centuries which is
demographics for example
what is the risk of dying at age 60 at
age 61 at age 62
this is called demographics and we we
see these uh demographic laws that i'll
talk about
and what i want to do in this talk is to
con to connect these two levels which
don't talk to each other generally
the demographics and the molecular
theory of aging and come up with what is
the core
process of aging or one of them that we
can address
um yeah so if we start with
if we start with uh demographics i can
tell you some facts
for example if you take identically twin
mice
and raise them in the same conditions
they die at different times so the
survival fraction
the fraction that survived to a given
age
um
is basically the same variation as
between two unrelated mice also people
if you take genetically identical twins
the they die at different times
almost like just random people from the
population
and the heredity of longevity is about
20
or less it's not that much so it's not
that
only the genes and it's not only the
environment there's something else
stochastic
like a clock that's running at different
times in different individuals
it's beyond the environment and beyond
their genes
that's one striking thing about about
aging
i'm looking at the q a
and what other animals does this work
it's there's clinical trials in human
beings i'll tell you about by the way
also disclosure i'm not in any company
i'm not going to try to sell you
anything
i don't have advice about your health
just going to tell you about some
mathematics how does this relate to the
old blood new blood transfusion work
uh it doesn't relate um and in fact that
that work is kind of shady in my opinion
why not try primates okay
um continuing on in the talk
uh one thing that we know from
demographics for about 150 years already
thanks to the work of
gompertz was a mathematician british
mathematician
because he was jewish he couldn't get
work as a mathematician
he worked in an insurance company
calculating the odds like what's your
probability of dying at a given age
and he's covered it's exponential she
says graph is amazing on the
x-axis is your age 20 40 68. and the
y-axis is your probability to die in a
given year
so when you're just born it's kind of a
you know one in a
few thousands and then in teenage it's
very low and then starts going up
and it goes up exponentially so it
doubles about every eight years
that's the gompert's law so every eight
years your risk of dying in a given year
rises and then kind of slows down at the
age 120
above age 100 people think it's about 50
chance to die in a given year
so when somebody reaches 120 in his
birthday you can say
have a nice day
and see q and a will the delayed aging
process also delay the physical
developing or intelligence gaining
process
so if
we delay aging usually we think about
doing that at
starting at old age so we can
probably by that time physical and in
intellectual development is done even
though
the spiritual in wisdom development
i hope will go on
okay i'm going to continue um
and now i'm going to jump to the biology
from the demographics to biology and
i'll tell you already what
we believe we i mean a large part of the
field of biology of aging
think is the culprit or is the
biological entity that accumulates with
age
that is causal for aging and when i say
accumulates with age if you look at this
graph
there's something so different between
being 20 and being 80 i mean i want to
also say that
20 year olds in terms of health most of
them are really like replicas they're
like
mass produced poster whereas an 80 year
old
they're all so different some of them
are so
some of them have the health of a 50
year old some of them have the health of
uh you know
90 year old that some of them are can't
walk some of them are doing marathons
etc
so the variation increases with age
in almost every trait and so every 80
year old
health is like a unique work of art
it's a unique combination
so here's what we think is accumulating
with age
um that makes the decade of 20 to 30 so
different from decade of 70 to 80.
they're kind of a state of our cells
they're called senescent cells
and cells are
um cells that are damaged so when a
normal cell becomes damaged
it has it tries to repair the damage if
it can't repair the damage it either
commits suicide that's called apoptosis
or it becomes a zombie cell senescent
cell
think of it like a zombie cell it's
large metabolically very active
and it causes it stops dividing
it it takes a few days for a cell to
become a sin essential
and it is very active and
these cells are uh actually have a very
important role
when you're young they have a role when
we are injured so suppose you have an
injury
somewhere and you have some damaged
cells if all the cells there committed
suicide and died
you would have a hole in your tissue
so instead the cells become senescent
cells and they kind of
hold the fort and they also secrete
chemicals that call in
the immune system to repair that's
called inflammation so senescent cells
make inflammation
swelling redness see hidden pain around
the area
by secreting signals that cause
inflammation the immune system comes in
they're like garbage trucks that clear
the senescent cells
and when the nest cells are cleared the
tissue regenerates
that's why senescence we have senescent
cells they play a crucial role
in wound healing okay
they secrete what's called
pro-inflammatory signals as i said
for the experts il-6 il-1 tnf these kind
of pro-inflammatory signals
they inhibit local regeneration so
tissue doesn't regenerate until
senescent cells are removed by those
garbage trucks the macrophages and the
nk cells of the immune system
but listen to this they're great when
we're young
but we're not designed to be old so this
is the thing about aging
aging as far as we know right now most
biologists think it's not a program that
says
okay at age 60 you'll have gray hair at
age 70 you'll have no hair and cataract
as a program to get rid of the old
professors to make room for new faculty
that's not the
what looks like happening aging instead
is this
it's evolution natural selection trying
to make us very fit when we're young so
we can make babies
pass on our genes but uh
after the typical time span where
the animal is not eaten by predators
all this investment in being fit when
you're young comes at the expense
of not having repair when you're old
so it's basically what happens is that
things go out of whack when you're old
and one of the things that go out of
whack is
that senescent cells accumulate with age
in humans and in mice in different
tissues and actually they accumulate
almost exponentially with age so
think about this these cells that were
so useful
for wound healing are now accumulating
all over our body with age and in this
talk i'll tell you why
and so our whole body is full of
inflammation
that's called inflammation these cells
are secreting these inflammatory signals
all over our body
they're also causing this body to stop
regenerating just like they did
as if there's an injury so they're doing
what they think is right because they
think we're still young
and they're causing inflammation and
reducing regeneration all over the body
and that is a huge factor in most aging
related diseases
and this is what is the difference
between the two mice i told you about
these two mice are genetically
engineered
so that you can
kill their senescence cells but for
experts i'll say the censor cells
express
a protein called p16 which stops the
cell cycle
there's a few also a few other nonsense
cells that do that but let's ignore that
for a second
and these genetically um
modified mice have a poison attack to
the p-16 promoter
that only works when you add a drug you
give them some kind of
drug and then when you give them that
drug
the senescent cells die so these mice
there's a way to kill senescent cells
and the difference between these two
mice is that the mice of the shiny mice
mouse
since one year of age was given this
treatment and
had the semester cells killed
every once in a while and the one mouse
on the
left just got a placebo
so they're genetically identical twin
mice and one had some necessary moves
from middle age and on so that answers
the question
i was asked by four different people
what is the intervention that slowed
aging
etc um did the treated mice still look
younger when they were eventually die or
do they catch up with untreated mice
samuel asked do the mice catch up
so eventually there's other things
beyond senescent cells noncells is not
the only thing there's additional forms
of damage
so this delays aging but eventually
these mice die they usually die of
lymphomas
mice usually die of lymphomas and will
cov
telomeres telomeres is another theory of
aging and shortened telomeres lead to
senescent cells there's a question i'm
just reading up the questions
will cover teach us something new about
aging because we need a paradigm to
understand why older people
are so much more vulnerable exactly
and indeed in almost all infectious
diseases
it's the older people who are more
likely to die from this
and in many infectious diseases actually
also very young
but not in covet 19 so it's very
interesting and
i do i do believe that copenhagen will
again focus focus on the vulnerability
of aged people
is the immune system a crucial element
indeed it is and i'll tell you
why it is suppressed under stress
it is true so that's why um we think
that people in
low socioeconomic status usually you
have chronic stress or often have
chronic stress which is not
being stressed about
um something at your work or something
that's being stressed let's say we
taking care of a
parent with dementia or something
something you can't get out of
this kind of stress
increases cortisol levels decreases the
immune system and its immune system that
removes senescent cells so that's one
link
between aging and stress
um
all right i'm gonna continue with the
talk so thanks for the questions keep
keep them coming i'm gonna
try to answer them i'm grateful for your
questions
um so senescent cells are really in a
perfect position
to understand aging because almost every
kind of damage cell damage
leads to senescence like telomere
shortening
all kinds of dna damages there so all
these different
damage theories of aging are okay so if
you
screw up dna repair dna damage will
cause more senescence
more aging etc so they kind of sum up
all these different
damages and they lead to
serious systems level effects
like chronic inflammation and stem cell
exhaustion
which lead to many diseases so they're
at a perfect place to
understand aging and also to treat aging
because as they started if you remove
some of themselves
if your muscular cells not only makes
the mice shiny
and their eyes bright etc there are
mouse models of diseases so there's
mouse models which have things that look
like
glaucoma idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis
atherosclerosis liver cirrhosis
all these osis i hope
we don't hear of these hoses okay but if
we do
it's good to have these mouse models
type 2 diabetes
muscle loss ulcers and in every one of
these diseases
removing senescent cells helped either
reverse
or ameliorate the disease
that i want to add to this list
alzheimer's disease mouse models
they're not perfect but they're and um
the list is going daily and there's
different ways to remove senescent cells
there's what's called synalytic drugs
these analytic drugs
what they do is they
latch on to something that's different
between cenas and cells and all the
other cells of
our body for instance census cells
stop their own suicide programs because
they don't they don't die
so if you interfere with that they die
more
and so some of those symbolic drugs do
that there's several classes of symbolic
drugs
and as i said and since 2019 there's
already some clinical trials for
idiopathic
pulmonary fibrosis and osteoarthritis
and human beings with analytics
based on this mouse work we still don't
know what the
results are but it's definitely a
promising direction
um
if we eliminate senescent cells there's
a question
and it rescues the disease
process involved in aging but the mouse
that could have been that has been
treated only enjoys a 25
increase in longevity and could this
mean that there are separate systems
involved in the process of aging versus
longevity
so i think the reason that these mice
don't live longer than 25
is that senescence are only part of the
answer
they are i think there's a lot of
damaged cells that somehow mention not
to become senescent but they can still
disturb our physiology so even if you
get rid of austenes and cells you can
enjoy
um delaying a lot of diseases but
there'll still be decline
eventually and so we need to find the
next layer in the onion
and akash
just ask what's the difference between
clock and environment in this context
are they related
i'm not sure i understand that so maybe
you can clarify
um
what about the decreased likelihood or
trend of death over 100 i'll address
that
i'll address that too okay so let's i'm
going to continue
um okay so what i now
i want to talk a little bit about the
role of mathematics as always
in my opinion biology mathematics is a
kind of a scaffold
that helps us ask new questions answer
them
in powerful ways they should go from
assumptions to solutions in a
powerful way and at the end you come up
with an answer that can be tested
experimentally and can be explained
without the mathematics
and if you can't do that experimentally
test it and explain it without the
mathematics you haven't done your job
so i'm going to try to my goal is that
everyone in this
webinar is going to understand what i'm
talking about without
the mathematics and that'll test my
ability to
explain to to see if i really understand
it um
and we started by asking okay senescent
cells accumulate with age and that's
that's the reason we think that um
that drives a lot of the aging process
and so
it wasn't known when we started do they
just accumulate this is
just like stay there forever more and
more made more and more and more in a
community like that or
are they actually made destroyed made
destroyed made very quickly
and what happens is that something like
um their removal rate goes down with age
or their production rate goes up with
age to
shift the balance and so nothing was
known about that
or very little what is the half-life of
senescent cells what's going on with
aging what explains the
vast difference between individuals with
age
so it must be some kind of stochastic
process stochastic means random process
and there mathematics can really help
because you can't
start thinking about this without the
precision of stochastic ordinary
differential equations
and things like that and we had some
data to work on so we weren't just
groping in the dark
we used a beautiful experiment done by
sharpless bird it all
in 2013 and they made mice
which are genetically engineered
and these mice they're engineered so
their senescent cells
emit photons as theirs and s cells make
light
and you can photograph these mice and
count or measure how much senescent
cells they have
and so you get on the x-axis is age in
weeks
they they had to stop this experiment
around late middle age because
the way they did this construct
interfered with some
part of the biology of these mice and
they had um
at old age they have some problems but
at young age it's
okay and this is on the y-axis it's
a light and each point here is a
different mouse
so you can see the there's just few
senescence cells at young age
and a lot of sinister cells in some of
the mouse in old age but you can see the
variation is huge
in the old mice you know some of them
are is fusing cells just like young mice
i hope you can see that i hope you can
see my
cursor can one of the panelists tell me
can you see my little arrow here
yes oh great so so you see the average
goes up
the variation becomes huge at all the
mice so we have
a lot of a lot of senses i'll somehow
have just a little
okay and um
and we got from these uh researchers a
very precious thing
connecting the dots so the mice aren't
killed in this experiment
you can see this green mouse you can see
their senescent cells over time so it's
what's called longitudinal or this
purple mouse is here so you can see them
go up and down
and this data has noise in it but from
beyond the noise you can use it to
analyze
and answer questions about the
production and removal of senescent
cells
the mathematics says that the rate of
change of semester cells is
production minus removal plus noise
and this is kind of the essence of it
and
we searched through a lot of
mathematical models this is a very
beautiful thing you could do with
mathematics you can say
i'm going to make as many models as i
can think of that are consistent with
the biology
and as do they describe this data
and we came up with a minimal model this
is the one that's simplest
that the simplest model that can
describe this data
to within um that's in a satisfactory
way
is written here and we have by now
tested this model in many different ways
experimentally and
theoretically and we are gaining
confidence that it is
in the right direction to explain the
accumulation of senescent cells
um in this model
there is a production that rises with
age
a removal that is inhibited by senescent
cells themselves i'm going to explain it
and a simple kind of white noise term
so this model what we get from this data
is that senescent cells
are removed in a way that is
inhibited by senescent cells themselves
and the simplest way to understand that
is you have those garbage trucks coming
to remove them
and the more senescent cells you have
the more those garbage trucks are
overloaded so when you're young you're
like
a young village with a little bit of
garbage and you're given let's say 100
garbage trucks those are the immune
cells
and they're working fine but we're not
designed to be old when you're old you
have so much senescent cells
they're the same but you still have 100
garbage trucks because evolution works
by giving you
immune system for when you're young not
when you're old and they're overloaded
they're overloaded and you're
and that makes the sentences just pile
up and also
if you're injured or something you have
many more it's messing cells in there so
this kind of model i'm just going to
flash a few slides and say this model
describes
the data in a satisfactory way so the
black dots here are data
x-axis is age y-axis senescent cells
you get the not only the average also
the distributions of senescent cells
between different mice which are
widening with age
and the standard deviation etc
um you have something very
uh important which is that
when you're old if you have more
senescent cells
than average you stay that way for a
long long time
so that means there's senescent cells
stay there or if you're lucky enough to
have a few senescent cells
you below average let's just say you're
healthy for a long period of time when
you're young
things balance out very quickly and
you'll go above average
and that is again because of those
garbage trucks when they're overloaded
if you have some extra sensors just stay
there for a long time uh so there's more
persistence and that kind of explains
the variation
in semester cells between individuals
everything slows down the removal slows
down so if you're unlucky enough to have
a lot of sense of cells
you stay that way for a long time
um it's fast dynamics when you're
young and persistent or slow dynamics
when you're old
um okay now
that model was interesting enough for us
to actually do an experiment
and to test it the model was predicting
not only that senescent cells turn over
quickly it told us exactly how quickly
told us that in young mice semester
cells are
removed every five days in an old mice
because of the slowdown of removal they
removed
every um month or so so that
they stick around for much longer and
that's part of the reason that they
accumulate
and that that was interesting enough to
actually do an experiment and the
experiment which we did with valerie
kuznovsky was aimed to measure the
half-life of senescent cells
and this is the way it's done you give
the mice
a bad drug that produces senescent cells
it's called bleomycin
in the lung so makes senescent cells
and then you see how long it takes
what happens with time so if there's no
removal of sensitive cells they just
stay there the
cells so slow removal they remove slowly
if there's fast removal
they're removed quickly we use kind of a
state-of-the-art method to measure the
senescent cells which is to
take out the lungs and put up a kind of
a marker of senescent cells and then
dissociate the whole
cells and move them through a machine
that takes a picture of each individual
cell
in different colors that's an imaging
flow cytometer for
experts so we can count the fraction of
cells that are senescent in the lung
and we found that in young mice
this extra senescent cells vanish with a
half-life of about five days
and in old mice which shows that they're
in a rapid balance of
production removal but in old mice they
stick around for a long time and have a
half-life of about
a month so
and that was very accurately predicted
by the model and that gave us a lot of
confidence
that indeed senescent cells are turned
over quickly in the young
and have a long half-life in the old
because we think they inhibit their own
removal rate um
and i'm just going to now ask
see if about the questions and let you
ponder what i'm saying
and the various diseases mortality rates
have similar age dependence indeed a lot
of diseases also go up exponentially
with age i'll talk about that at the end
of the talk and we think that the same
kind of model can explain
age-related disease incidents are so are
senescent cells
pre-apoptosis is signaling responsible
for difference between the cells
sensor cells are stop cell division and
they
don't commit cell death they're
anti-apoptosis i would say
and doesn't killing semester cells have
an adverse effect on repairing injuries
i think it does so i wouldn't advise
taking those drugs once
they exist after heart surgery or
something like that
when you're healing but they don't
appear to cause adverse effects in the
mice
unless they're injured so that's that's
interesting
it could um mutated mice could die from
a wound
so i suppose if you're injured and you
remove someone essence keep removing
sonos and cells that's not a good idea
but if you're injured you can just stop
removing cinnamon cells and you'll be
fine um but i'm so glad these questions
show that you're right on
you're with me or helps me see that i'm
clear
i hope i'm clear so mess with essentials
was more at risk when injured because
you need senescent cells for wood repair
yeah these questions are around the same
point
the thing is when you remove citizen
cells because of this half-life
you can stop removing them when the
mouse is injured
they will appear there for the
interaction for the repair
process and then once there's repair you
can continue removing senescent cells i
would
counsel that shouldn't having more sense
cells
induce stronger immune system
what's the difference between autophagy
and sinus and cells how does this remain
to the immune system so autophagy is a
kind of repair process in the cells
that addresses damaged proteins
if you mess up with autophagy you get
increased aging and you also get
senescence so autophagy is a kind of
anti-senescence
if you have more autophagy cells are
able to repair themselves you have less
autophagy
cells are become more senescence and
that's i think the one of the links
between autophagy and aging
and the immune system is the system that
removes senescent cells so
they know when cells are damaged and
they can remove some
cells especially nk cells and
macrophages
um does the age arrested most exhibit
behavior that is different from actual
young mice eats more moves less
you know that's something to be a
studied if you remove cinnamon cells is
the
mouse 100 like young mice i know that
uh if removing sensor cells can't
reverse
some aging phenotypes like damage to
muscle fibers is kind of
seems like a aging phenotype that can't
be removed when you remove some smells
but other
things apparently can a lot of um a lot
of
decline can so it's partially
you can become younger but i have seen
experiments done by valerie krzynovsky
my colleague where you take um an old
mouse
and inject a pseudomolytic drug that
removes the cells
and within a couple of days the mouse
starts running 10 hours a day on the
wheel
that's a mouse that was very old and
didn't run so
that was very striking and that lasted
for a month
and i was uh very impressed
to see that but there's a lot of work to
do about what exactly
is is reversible what isn't and of
course also when you translate to human
beings it could be
completely it's a lot of times things
don't translate from ice to human beings
so
if we it's a young field and
certainly having more senescent cells
induce stronger immune response in older
people
i think one thing that happens in old
people with a lot of cements and cells
is the immune system shifts
towards the part that removes the nasal
cells that's called the myeloid shift
more macrophages
and less t cells than b cells i believe
that's a i would guess that's the
response of the immune system to the
senescent cells
and that doesn't help us a lot with
things like covet 19 which needs t
cells and b cells okay i'm going to now
um stop with the questions for a second
and we'll have a vast amount of time
i think 30 minutes for ques for more
questions
i want to now link go back to the
question i ask can this understanding of
senescent cells
help us explain the gompert's law the
exponential rise in death
probability and to do that we need to
link
something cellular senescent cells
to death and cells
and death there's a vast gap
between the two so how can we go from
senescent cells
to death it's not clear yet and but
there's a lot of research about that
how um an individual mouse with a given
amount of senescent cells
does it die younger or older that link
needs a lot of mice experience which are
being done
but here we use mathematics again so
we know that sensor cells are involved
in many aging irregular diseases but
it's not only that you die from diseases
often you die of diseases
and here's the mathematics
you can explore simple-minded
hypotheses which are of course just an
approximation to probably
a more complicated reality and let's
play with the following
on the x-axis is your a is age and
y-axis is
how many senescent cells you have and
here are two individuals the blue and
the orange go up down up down
and let's imagine that you die when
sonesta cells cross
a threshold there's a level of cement
cells that's incompatible with life
x critical let's call it um
naturally that's just a simplified
assumption
you can also test other assumptions just
the probability of dying increases with
senescent cells in the kind of
functional
monotonically increasing function but
this
threshold one has the elegance that you
can actually analytically solve
the equation i showed you before this is
what's called the mathematics of first
passage time
so you ask when does the stochastic
process like sinus and cells first cross
of breath
threshold it's a famous problem first
passage time problem
with a long history in chemical physics
etc
and you can solve it for the equation
that i showed
and you basically get
um the gompert's law you get an
exponentially increasing
rate of depth uh here the red line is
the simulation or the
if you want the the theory we added to
it
um some something called extrinsic
mortality so when
between age 20 and 40 notice here
most deaths aren't caused from aging
related
reasons they're caused by accidents
suicide
homicide especially in men
if you factor those out this exponential
line you just take those out
the risk of that goes down exponentially
down to here so another decade of
exponential
so we added here the extrinsic mortality
but in amazing thing is that this
has no free parameters you take the same
parameters you fit to the senescent cell
production removal etcetera and then
just add a threshold and you get this
exponential rate not only the
exponential which you can now connect
to basic molecular parameters like the
noise and the threshold and the rate of
production
cells etc you also get this slowing down
the question was asked
what happens at age 100. so this also
comes out of this model
and it has to do with um
removal being so slow that now the
amount of sense of cells is governed by
noise
and when it's governed by a noise it
becomes what's called a random walk
process and then the the crossing of
this threshold becomes
basically a constant probability per
unit time
i what i just said is for experts to
understand um stochastic process or math
random walks um it's basically a luck
game when at that age of course you have
the genes to make sure that you haven't
died from
other causes but it's not only genes
it's uh
it's also luck that um
that plays a role here um
as far as we see things it has a major
major role
so we can understand the slowdown at old
ages from the same mall
now we come to diseases this last part
i'm just gonna make sure i haven't
missed any questions here i apologize if
i missed questions
um the adverse effects of symmetric
drugs
so you know there's different classes
some of them are
have side effects because they stop
let's see some of them have side effects
some of them have don't have serious
side effects as far as safety
trials and humans have shown those with
strong side effects
can be used let's say for osteoarthritis
by injecting them into the joints
because there they don't go into the
outs rest of the body and they have
local effects
but it's early days and it's possible
that they'll have adverse effects we
don't we don't
know about apart from their role in
wound healing
so it'll be interesting to see of course
the
thing in biology is you discover
something
you believe it's going to cure big
diseases and
usually there's maybe an early success
but then in the end
it's not as as optimistic as you thought
in the beginning
we're right now in the very optimistic
phase because we still don't know the
results of big clinical trials on the
other hand
uh killing senescent cells is much
easier than killing cancer cells cancer
cells
mutate and you know they're so clever
and they're so similar to our cells
they're
they're really a dangerous foe so
necessarily don't
divide they don't mutate they just sit
there and so killing them
should be easier and also strengthening
the immune system to kill them is
there's just been a paper by a low lab
about using um like uh immune therapy
against cancer by
designing t cells to kill cancer cells
doing the same for
senescent cells so they designed t cells
to kill some essentials take out your
own t
cells engineer them to recognize the
protein on cinnamon cells so there's
at least two strategies analytic drugs
and immune therapy
and i believe there'll be something that
works
um that's my my gut
feeling early days um
yeah the mice don't have adverse
phenotypes the mice only have benefits
as far as
there's maybe 50 reports with different
labs now so they all
say that what can macrophages clear out
sonos and cells during wound healing
but now once they start to accumulate
the the point i think is that senescent
cells become so numerous
that they overwhelm the body's ability
to remove them and they also probably
um and that's a numbers game as far as
they can tell
so why do why does their production rate
increase with age
that's because we as we age we have more
and more mutations and stem cells get
mutated
producing damaged cells all over our
body and that rate
rises linearly with h because the amount
of stem cell divisions is
constant and so you have a stem cell
mutant here here here here here
and above it is a column of senescent
cells so the production rate increases
literally with age
your hundred garbage trucks all the
macrophages are get overwhelmed
and then it goes up like this because
removal so
then with the noise it's uh it's really
interesting to think about
um uh if sensors release some sort of
not super targeted chemical that
inhibits regeneration this does this
mean
that sufficient quantity of senescent
cells can inhibit regeneration of a lot
of healthy cells in the area
how important is this to the aging
process so this question i think
very deep so necessarily indeed release
factors that slow down regeneration in
their own area
and also systemically and this is
in my opinion very important for the
aging processes and at the core of some
aging related diseases
especially degenerative diseases where
removal of cells needs to be more than
proliferation of cells but if
proliferation
proliferation needs to be more than
removable but if you stop proliferation
it goes below removal a tissue crashes
that's our explanation for
idiopathic pulmonary fibrosis and for
osteoarthritis and a lot of diseases
like that so i think it's very important
um so so many questions
64 questions i don't think i can answer
all the questions
uh right now what do you think about the
hogwarts clock
what did the mouse 2 tend to die of are
there trends and diseases
yeah actually that's not clear yet um
what what do treated mice die of i think
it's mostly
lymphomas in mice because of some
strange reason they they're very prone
to lymphoma
shouldn't having more senescent cells
induce stronger immune response okay we
already did that
okay um what about nad plus studies
show that supplementation is a dramatic
anti-energy effect so i think a lot of
anti-aging studies address
factors that connect also to synthetic
they have their own effects but also
they
connect to senescent cells for example
um
calorie restriction mtor inhibitors all
these
increase repair in cells and their
repair
prevents senescence and so
there's a lot of connection between
different anti-aging
interventions in mice and senescent
cells of course
sentences aren't the only thing white
production is writing linearly in time i
think i answered that because of stem
cell
mutations surgically having old mouse
shares blood supply with the young ones
seems to reverse aging
has been the show to yeah so andrew
clark says
if you take an old mouse and connect
circulation to a young mouse so now you
have siamese twin mice that's called
parabiosis
they can stay like that for a few months
the old mice rejuvenates
and the young mice slightly ages and
recently
there's a paper measuring senescent
cells and indeed the old mouse
has synaptic cells reduced and we
the way we explain this is that the
the garbage trucks from the young mice
go through the circulation to the old
mouse
and help that big city with a lot of
garbage remove garbage i hope i'm being
clear so we think
what happens is that the saturated
removal capacity of the old mice
is alleviated by making an alliance by
having
shared circulation with the young models
so that can be explained actually
perfectly by the same model
quantitatively so we think that's an
explanation it's
we don't think it's only a bloodborne
factor and we think it's the immune
system that's moving
that's our uh unpublished um manuscript
if anyone's interested i can send you
that we want to try to submit that
it's possible that an ancient
civilization slowed this chemical
process enough
to be 80 years and look 20 years
it is possible uh
but yeah i wonder what the fossil like
um if there would be like a layer with
uh
with a lot of like we could layer in the
okay i looked at the rocks in the golan
you can see the you know the
volcanic and then there's like sediment
and so i wonder what that
layer that ancient civilization would
look like a lot of like
jogging 80 year olds can the exponential
increase be explained by the
hierarchical nature of biological
circuits
um it can
but i like and of course i love networks
and hierarchical circuits but
i more love this very simple stochastic
equation that captures so much
with so little so um that's my favorite
explanation right now
okay let's talk about incidents of
diseases there was a question
on the x-axis is the age and the y-axis
is the chance
to get the disease it's called incidence
so the this is for example or or
condition the this is hypertension okay
this is log scale by the way here uh
diabetes
here we have heart attack this is
um ipf this is uh lung failure
the black line you have kidney failure
disease after disease i mean not every
disease is aging related for instance
type 1 diabetes you get at age 11.
you know thyroiditis you get at age
your teenage depression
um is age related but you also can get
young ages but
many diseases are age-related diseases
we looked at the israel's medical record
we found 800 disease codes which
rise by a factor of 30 between when
you're 20 and you're 80. and
they all have the same general
exponential rise you see the exponential
rise with very similar slope
six to eight percent per year not the
same slope as death
death probability but similar slope and
they have this decline at old age it's
not as it's not a plateau
it's actually decline at slow ages
decline slowly
decline at slow ages long ages what is
going on here
this again hints at a shared co process
that times the diseases of course which
disease you get does matter it doesn't
matter what your genes are it doesn't
matter what your environment is if you
have the genes and the lack of exercise
and nutrition
you get you'll get diabetes um whereas
people with other genes or another
behavior won't so it does depend very
much
but you still have this exponential rise
and decayed old ages and we found that
we can
explain all of these curves using the
same
kind of model as i said before and
link it to uh senescence cells
i'm not saying sensor cells are the only
cause but they're sufficient
to give you this uh kind of curve no
there's been theories in the past let's
say cancer incidence
cancer also has similar most cancers
that you have needed multiple hits like
two three mutations at the same time
they give you power law behavior
but there was never a theory that
connects all these very different
diseases
and we think some lesson cells can do
that and
basically what it says is that you have
a physiological process that causes
crosses a threshold like let's say
proliferation and removal of the cells
once once
cells are removed more than they can
divide you the organ crashes or in
cancer
once cancer cells divide more than
they're removed by the immune system
the cancer takes off so and if senescent
cells affect those rates there'll be a
threshold citizen cells for the onset of
the disease
and as i said before that's the first
passage time problem you get this
exponential rise
why the drop in old ages it's a very
simple epidemiological principle
not everyone is susceptible to diabetes
at a certain age any everyone who
is susceptible will already have gotten
it
right so that's why you have a decline
at all the ages
the susceptible population is a fraction
of the population and everyone who
whatever is susceptible has already
gotten a certain age so
age 90 a lot of diseases are actually on
the decline in terms of incidence
um and as i said before if you just take
one threshold for each disease the
dashed lines their models
and the susceptibility what's the
fraction you get
you can explain a lot of these curves
satisfactorily
and then what you could do is you can
predict what happens when you take those
drugs that removes some essentials or
immune therapy
so then you can do a model for a disease
age on the x-axis disease goes up
er enzymes goes up and down right
it's very important for these drugs to
because they might have side effects
to design treatments with the lowest
possible dose
and the most infrequent treatment you
don't want the treatments to be far away
from each other to minimize side effects
now you can
these models you can calculate so here's
a very modest treatment
you take the the drug starting at age 60
it removes some essentials
it removes only a quarter of the
senescent cells
and you take it once every two months
why do we know two months because we
we know the half-life of senescent cells
at least in mice and we have a reason to
believe in humans
it's similar so we know we don't need to
remove them every day
because we know that it takes them two
months to accumulate again we know that
from them mall
and this modernist treatment makes the
incidents
plummet and you still age
but your incidence at age 80 is like the
incidence of a person at age 60
or something at 85 like this is a
25-year rejuvenation
in terms of diseases
and then you can make plot the dose
versus the time interval and see
how many years rejuvenated a strong dose
taken very very
frequently will give you a high
rejuvenation and
etc so you can argue or
suppose with these meth tests with these
mathematical models what's the optimal
treatment
you can start at old age and take it in
frequently and kill only a fraction of
the cells and believe that cessna cells
will only affect
a fraction of the diseases causing
potential and still get a sizeable
rejuvenation in terms of years and
that's
um that's uh exciting for us to
pursue and also um
i want to say that this way of thinking
creates novel
explanations for mysterious diseases
like idiopathic problems fibrosis
osteoarthritis we can explain what
exactly the senescent cells are doing to
basic physiological
parameters and provide new explanations
for
mysterious diseases um but i think it's
a good time to stop and take your
questions so
we found out that
one way to think about aging is that
there's a core process
that runs like um randomly it's produced
production increases with age
it saturates its own removal and that
coupled with noise creates a stochastic
dynamics that makes people much more
different from each other with age
and it creates a first passage time
where you have
exponential rise in risk of disease and
death
it can explain slow down at old ages and
decline in disease incidents
it can explain probiosis what happens
when you look up link up to mice
and you can explain a lot of other
factors in aging
that i won't um that i can answer if you
want
but we think it's a minimal description
that explains a lot and of course
there's other things
too and turnover slows down an
old mice leading to large and persistent
variation in semester cells between
individuals
which can explain the gombert's law of
variation mortality and
disease these are the linked up mice by
the way
and um i believe we can
um okay there's 67 questions
hal cox says thank you worry i hope your
talk can be posted blessings on the
stream of the galilee
may they continue to run what a
beautiful comment
thank you nimrod rubenstein many of the
parabolic studies that are replicated
with plasma transfers immune cells
cannot be all the only explanation right
what's your opinion on these studies
so what nimrod is saying is that if you
connect to mice so they share
circulation you get some effects
and then if you take plasma that is the
only
blood without immune cells and transfer
it from one mouse to the other
you get replication
of the superbiotic studies now i might
be missing a paper
and maybe numerous maybe you're an
expert and you can teach me something
new
but as far as i know those
plasma transfers have been done for
brief amount of periods of time and as
far as i know they don't
really replicate the full effects of
parabolas
and please correct me if i'm wrong so
there's a long
a search for the plasma factors but as
far as i know there's not a satisfactory
replication of plasma transfer
it could be out out of date so
please correct me maria
does the model consider the effects
of different removal rates in time such
the increase in senescence is due to
reaching a passage to remove it maybe
due to a depletion of the garbage trucks
thank you so what maria is saying maybe
if i understand correctly the garbage
trucks
are becoming damaged our immune system
is going down with stage
and that would also give you an increase
in senescence so
that's um very likely because we know
that our immune system gets worse with
age
but the main part that gets worse with
age are those t cells and
b cells the adaptive immune system the
part that removes the nasal cells
nk cells and macrophages doesn't seem to
get much worse with age
in fact it stays kind of constant with
age maybe macrophages increase
they do look more exhausted which is
what you would expect if they're working
very hard
so um we
think that right now our best hypothesis
is that you don't have to
invoke the garbage trucks themselves
becoming worse with age
only that they become saturated or
inhibited but i'm sure
that there's also a component of them
being worse with age which will only
compound the effects
that's the way we look at it right now
but that's a question for the
frontier of research right now if
susceptibility
rug is asking if susceptibility of
disease incidence is from increase in
senior essence cells
production increases with age does it
mean that folks who are not susceptible
for disease do not
establish with age the question is about
what do i mean by susceptible with
disease so i think
everyone has increasing production in
senescent cells with age
some of us are luckier or not in the
stochastic process and at
age 80 we might have more or less than
the average
based on genetics and environment but
mostly unluck this way look now
susceptibility is something else
it's easy to understand smokers if
you're smoking you're much more
susceptible to lung cancer
yeah so
by the age of 80 if you are smoking and
not have
lung cancer the incidence you're in the
down curve you probably don't have the
genes for lung cancer or something like
that it's
so the susceptibility is a lot to do
with genetics and environment
and you're born with the genes they'll
give you this so most people
luckily well not susceptible to let's
say
pancreatic cancer and they will never
get it
and some people are and
maybe pancake cancer is not such a great
example because
let's say let's talk about um
osteoarthritis even it looks like
there's only a fraction of people that
will ever get osteoarthritis and that's
completed by a certain age or also
diabetes or hypertension etc
that's the leading epidemiological role
it's not not
senescent cells it's the
fragility of a certain organ system to
the effects of senescent cells let's
call it like that
does the neighboring cells become
cancerous if something cells are removed
so
janet is alluding to a role in senescent
cells of preventing cancer it's thought
that
a lot of cancer cells become senescent
and they stop dividing but it doesn't
look like it doesn't look that removing
sensitive cells
increases the risk of cancer as far as i
know
nimrod says i meant more generally
rejuvenation
so nimrod do you know if plasma exchange
actually causes rejuvenation because i
haven't
seen convincing data about that so if
you know about that
please tell me i mean there's
some kind of companies that are
doing research that's um
they would be careful to
over interpret so but
academic labs that are credible
i haven't seen that but if there's a ref
reference please
tell me what of course they could be
um not up to date why do big dogs age so
much faster than small dogs
somehow body-sized relationships ah
great question why do big dogs age so
much faster than small dogs
so i was pondering this question and i
know
i know that part of the mutations
in the breeding process of big dogs and
small dogs are in the same pathway
as that's targeted by anti-aging
intervention so
one of those pathways is the igf-1 the
growth
the growth pathway so if you
want a big dog you make the cells
activate their growth pathway
when cells activate the growth pathway
there's a trade-off they make less
repair so growth and repair
are in a trade-off you grow more
resources to growth less resources to
repair
so when you grow faster you have less
repair
and therefore more damage more
senescence
faster aging drugs that uh calorie
restriction for example
makes you grow less and have more repair
and therefore
calorie restriction in many organisms
slows down aging also
metformin the anti-diabetes drug is a
good candidate for slowing down the same
igf-1 pathway
and apparently slows aging because of
increased repair less in essence at
least that's one so i think i love the
small dog question
are the middle-aged mice reproductive
why would natural selection have
selected for the production of more and
better garbage trucks
so
why should national selection give us uh
just increase the number of garbage
truck as we age right why do we need
why do we need to stick with a hundred
garbage trucks why can't we have a
thousand garbage trucks over age
mice are reproductive right so natural
selection should um
work is there so if we look at mice
um why do mice live two years it's
because in
nature their average time before they're
killed by a predator is about one year
and that's what sets their half-life so
their lifespan so that we think it's
called life history
theory and that's it's like you have a
car and if you know that it's going to
be stolen
within a month you don't go to the
garage and repair it and buy
extra do that so you can be stolen right
so the same thing with creatures
on the other hand if you have a naked
mole rat it's like about the same size
as a mouse or a rat
lives underground it lives for 40 years
because it's never
printed it's protected so the natural
killing rate in nature is what sets what
evolution set lifespan what does that
mean evolution said glass but
it's basically how much you devote to
growth reproduction versus repair so
mice
they're reproductive they live fast die
young
leave a good looking corpse and leave a
lot of babies that's their strategy
they're going to be eaten in the year so
they do a lot of they do
very little repair that's why it's so
easy for biologists to give mice cancer
anything you know it's so easy to give
mice cancer
they have very little repair human
beings elephants whales have a lot more
repair so we can make it to 800
and the apparently the reason different
mammals
evolved of different lifespan is by
playing with this trade-off of
reproduction
in growth versus repair in different
ways
and i hope i answered your question
kenneth
akash when we look at celestine cells
what kind of cells are we looking at
most of the time is the situation of
senescence different for a neuron
thank you so a lot of times
are cells that do tend to divide
so we're looking at epithelial cells of
the gut we're looking at
skin cells we're looking at lung cells
liver cells senescence cells neurons
don't divide anyway they don't really
become senescent i mean
they have different aging but their glia
the the helper cells around them do
become cinnamon
i want to say that from our mathematical
analysis
age-related diseases of the mind
parkinson's
alzheimer's disease they have a
different story
they have a much faster like the 20
increase per year or something like that
it's not explained by the cells in the
body and we thinking maybe there's
a senescent cell compartment in the
brain like the senescence glia or
something like that
the cells that maintain the neurons that
have their own dynamics
and can explain slightly different
dynamics for the age related diseases in
the in the main that's just a
hunch right now um but there's
synesthesis all over the body so
wherever there's stem cells you'll see
some nasty cells
near them in fat cells there's a lot of
senescent cells
in them etcetera the treatment you
mentioned seems to
affect only kappa can the generation
rate be affected so this is a marina
um um
showing great attention to the equation
that i showed
the treatments i mentioned er effect
only kappa which is a halfway point for
saturation i would say the treatments
what they do
is they add an additional removal term
that's very strong
like like beta you can say or something
like that in the equations
and um and you can model them that way
and but maybe adding more immune cells
can affect kappa
something like that and james asks do
animals in these studies
observably age at different rates or do
are they just randomly die after
different times
there's there's a lack of experiments on
the
aging rate of animals treated in this
way there is this vendors and
experiments they're very difficult
experiments to do
they do but i'd say there's more to do
about that and especially what i'd like
to see is
connecting the time of death to the
amount of cinnamon cells
in an individual that's one unknown um
okay i'm going to go down and burn hard
i mean the mouse with killed some
essentials was more at risk when injured
because you need something else ruining
the repair
okay so bernard the way i look at it is
that you kill the senescent cells that
are already there
if now the mouse gets injured nutiness
cells will form you don't want to kill
them after injury you don't want to kill
citizen cells i would advise against
that but
after the injury is healed you can kill
continue killing senescent cells
so once you kill cinnamon cells you kill
the senescent cells
most of the cells you kill are the ones
that are made from the damaged
from the mutated stem cells not from a
wound
per se as far as i can tell jeff is
calorie restriction which also extends
life in mice related to this i think it
is because
as i said before calorie restriction
affects the igf-1 pathway it shifts the
cells towards
away from growth and towards repair and
the way i look at it is that it
reduces the probability that the damaged
cell becomes senescent because the cell
can repair itself
and therefore reduces actually the rate
of production of senescent cells
and that fits when we look at calorie
restriction in fruit flies
and in mice and we use these models
that's the parameter effect it's the
rate of production of senescent cells
um this is so intense you know these
questions they're coming there's um so
many questions 71 questions
through text we have to finish soon i
think
can i ask one of the panel members to
tell us how much time we have
yeah we have time for 12 30.
now we have another 10 minutes 10
minutes okay
um okay um ismail
have any of those treatments been
applied to humans so as i said there's a
couple of trials now
one for idiopathic pulmonary for roses
terrible disease that
lungs stop working and you die within a
year or two
so removing senescent cells helps that
mice with the same
model for that disease and now there's a
trial with synalytic drugs and also for
osteoarthritis
maybe more um
can fasting kill these cells i don't
think fasting kills those cells
i think fasting increases repair
and reduces the rate of production of
semester cells that's the way
we think what do you sarah what do you
think about the whole varsity clock so
hover clock
is a big advance where you can look at
the dna of organism and look at certain
places and see how they're modified
and get a good reading of the age of the
organism
i believe that those
changes are markers
for the effects of things like
inflammation and and therefore they
are likely to be a good reporter of the
physiological age of a human being and i
think very important for developing
drugs
i want to say that there's a kind of a
an attempt in the field
to get the fda to approve clinical
trials against
aging itself and not only currently it's
it trials only against the disease like
diabetes so
if you have a good clock like the whole
earth clock where you can
measure the effects of treatments
against aging
you can have additional tools to assess
whether drugs are working or not
a role of proper nutrition in aging so
of course
proven
nutrition is key for um preventing
obesity overweight which causes many
problems including
inflammation and um
insulin resistance etc vitamins are very
important it's a good
balance maybe even um
setting the balance between growth and
repair
that's something to think about fasting
and
i believe will be a very important
factor raju any data that showed
oh shy ben david when you go over many
models don't you risk over fitting
so um what what we did was
develop four possible mechanisms
and therefore two to the power for 16
different models
and we used bayesian
statistics to make sure we're not
overfitting
so we were very worried about that and
if you'd like to take a look at the
paper maybe
you can enlighten us if you think that's
valid it's korean at all 2019.
and michael levy do you get quality
different results without the white
noise term yeah
without noise you can't make this work
you can't
uh explain the data as far as we can
tell with deterministic models you need
to have noise
because of the huge increasing
stochasticity so
noise is crucial if you're asking
whether white noise versus non-white
noise
i'm not saying the noise is white i'm
saying that white noise is a minimal
model that's sufficient to explain the
data we have but it could be the noise
is not white
probably isn't in reality is there info
on position of cells emil is asking
that's an emerging field right now
there's an
um a race to make mice that have good
fluorescent markers of senescent cells
they're readable at old age
um and i would predict that what you'll
see is a
stem cells with a column of cinnamon
cells above them so you'll see a
punctuate
but there is one paper from the
bunderson lab that showed some
very low concentration of senescent
cells with a huge effect on the heart
so anyway that's fascinating i don't
know i don't know what to say
um during healthy aging what causes
increasing synthesis of production with
age
it's very simple it's stem cells divide
and when divided they mutate some of
those mutations kill the stem cell or
make it
go away but some of them are invisible
to the stem cell and only expressing the
cells of the body differentiated cells
making them damaged and then
become senescent and the amount of
mutants in cells rises with the number
of mutations
going on in concentrates so their number
increases linearly with age all over the
body you get more and more senescence
how did you test the goodness of fit for
the trajectories as i said we used um
about asian kind of simulator and we
used
log likelihood for the trajectories
around
can a model for some cell's population
dynamics be bi or multi-stable
indeed if sonesta cells
strongly make neighboring cells also
senescent in a bystander effect you can
get a
by stability then you can get a let's
say a wound let's say with
cells that don't go away and surgeons
know sometimes you need to remove some
of themselves for the wound to
heal so that could be an example of
bistability
um so in your equation you smell is
asking the noise factor does not depend
on time
yeah we tested models where noise
depends on time but we found we didn't
need to do that
but again let's say a minimal model
um so nice questions um
maria interesting model i appreciate it
describes the data but it is provided a
new prediction so
one new prediction was the lifetime of
senescence cells that we actually
thought was interesting enough to test
experiments so that was a prediction an
unknown senescent cells now we know turn
over
five days in the young mice and one
month in the old mosque that was a
prediction
panned out and now another prediction is
what i showed you
at the end we can now predict what a
treatment would
do to the incidence of diseases so
could be that one day down the line
we'll have data like that
and that can help us design new
experiments and that's a very new
important ability in order to design
optimal treatments with minimal side
effects maria i hope i address your
question
um what about the production of these
cells is exponential
the production is linear with time but
since removal saturates
it gives it extra boost it looks almost
exponential we don't think that
production saturates um
can i ask a question which appears but
uh i don't think you got to it i think
several people asked it why does
the why do you think the rate of
production of sales goes up in time
why does that happen so um i answered it
or
three times but it probably wasn't clear
okay
so the idea is that all of our so we
were thinking
what what stays in the body for decades
it's not the cells like our skin cells
that get removed every month
or blood cells get removed every 100
days it has to be something that stays
what stays
the stem cells they stay stem cells make
all the other cells
now the stem cells are dividing into
concentrate throughout adult life once
in a while they get a mutation
some of those mutations make the cells
they produce the column of cells above
them damaged
those cells think there's an injury
they're damaged and they become
senescent
now the rate that happens because the
divided concentrate
is linear in time so you have a mutant
stem cell here then here
then here then here then here and that's
a linear process with time did i explain
myself chaffey yeah so the point is
you're saying that senescent cells get
created when they think that they need
to repair something
or they know since the cells are there
they make yeah
stem cells are there when they get
mutated they make damaged cells and the
damaged cells
what do damaged cells do they become
senescent so the mutations the problem
is that you can
every time cells divide there's a chance
for a mutation
and therefore you get it looks like an
injury because you have damaged cells
but it's not really an injury it's just
a damaged stem cell
making injured cells all and that
did i explain yourself yeah yeah yeah
right so necessarily they're doing what
they they think they're doing right they
think oh we're damaged we have to call
them the immune system
we have to stop stop uh regeneration
they're doing what they should
but we're not designed to live in
so long we're not designed to live that
long and we're not designed to have
so many cement cells it's just like
having injury all over our body
our poor macrophages and mk cells can't
deal with it they also by the way empty
cells can't do what they're supposed to
do they can't kill virus
infected cells and cancer cells and so
when we have a lot of senescent cells
we can't deal with cancer in in covet 19
et cetera
because those same cells are busy with
the census cell so we
it's multiple layers of of
decline that are rolled up in these
senescent cells
as far as we could yes kudzunis and
cells
density ratio could use as a
quantification of aging is there
currently a marker
so um i believe that
if we could measure from a human being
the amount of senescent cells
we would have a great marker for aging
unfortunately that's not
possible right now um
in an easy blood test or something like
that even though there's a lot of
attempts to do that and i also want to
say the the methods quantitative
cells are not the best it's probably
likely that senescent cells are many
things each each cell type has a
different senescence program
and that because it's early days we
think of them with one entity but in
fact each
there's many many kinds of sentence
cells with different effects the reality
will turn out to be much more complex
than we think
and so it's still the optimism of early
days
but i do believe it's it's a really
great quantifier of aging once we get it
maybe the whole
clock is related to that
um there are few communities in the
world
okinawa sardinia with highest proportion
of centenarians
genetics seems to be one aspect also
some data in small communities is a
higher elevation
yeah there's uh communities with a lot
of
very old people and um
and i don't know i don't know what to
say about that um
so um
i think we're approaching our end yeah
maybe we should have a grand finale
there's so many questions i didn't
answer i feel bad about that
aloha uri lee altenberg hi lee
he's on in honolulu thanks for the great
visit in january isn't that nice
um yeah thank you uh uli this was like
amazing and in fact i wonder if we can
save the questions so maybe there's a
feature to do that and if you want
in your spare time during covid you can
send off answers
we'll try to do that i see that i only
answered 50
and there's 60 more yes so
i really apologize for if i didn't
answer your question
i think there's a way to save it that uh
the question so
if there is we'll do that but thank you
for tremendous talk
and uh i at least i'm a mute you know
one of the terrible thing about zoom is
that you cannot get the applause and the
you know i'm sure the actor in you is
craving for it
i am kind of gotten used to it by
teaching on zoom
but the questions and one person says
similar questions which means the
audience made the audience think
your questions made me think some of the
questions are new to me
and um yeah i hope we
i don't know somehow i hope first of all
we get to old age it's better than the
alternative
and also that we
i don't know learn how to you know all
those non-medicinal ways all the
relationships the connections
the community solidarity having
something meaningful in life
very important and to keep us going and
then
shafi i really enjoyed it what can i say
tremendous thank you so much bye
okay bye